Nietzsche said that every profound
Spirit needs a mask
like you said you don't like to talk
about
in your comedy you don't like to talk
about stuff that's personal to you yeah
and what is that what if you were to
psychoanalyze yourself do you think it's
just not something you find funny or is
it are you running from something
um
and uh it's not your fault well it's not
your fault well
um speaking of another really great
comedic actor who's also a serious actor
Robin Williams one of the best serious
actors I mean
I mean I I and you know one of the
funniest people of all time but as great
as incredible as he was as a funny man
as a as a stand-up and a performer I
almost like his his serious stuff better
can I ask you a question about that what
do you make of the that he committed
suicide I think it's I think it's I mean
it's super depressing I I I've referred
to him as like the Jesus Christ of of uh
depression it's almost like he died for
others depression you know what I mean
like yeah yeah you'd look at someone
like that and go wait a minute you're a
rock star like you don't you could just
check out if you're not liking your life
and of course something like suicide
begs that you look a little deeper and
uh realize how tortured the human mind
can can make someone